[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANUJ GOYAL: I'm Anuj Goyal.
I'm a product manager for
Chrome Browser Enterprise.
And here's the agenda today.
We're going to talk
about why the browser is
becoming increasingly
important in the enterprise.
We're going to talk about
Chrome browser benefits,
improvements since last year,
future enhancements that
are coming in 2019,
and finally, how to get
started managing Chrome
Browser Enterprise.
So let's get started.
We all know the way that
enterprise's work is changing.
This is being driven by
rapid technology changes.
What was once impossible
is now possible,
and what was once
possible is now normal.
Employees want flexibility,
agility, speed, and access
to what they want
when they want it.
People want to be able
to pick up their kids,
take calls from the car, work
from home, and respond to email
wherever they are.
We all know this and
experience this every day.
With the affordability
of cloud computing,
the reach of mobile
devices, and the ubiquity
of fast connectivity, technology
in the work environment
is vastly different
from what it used to be.
So let's look at some stats.
84% of people work in
virtual environments at least
part of the time.
On average, an
employee has 22 apps
and they have three devices.
Almost half of
those devices store
some business critical data.
And finally, remote work
is the norm for about 70%
of your traditional
information workers.
So what you need
is a secure browser
that can be managed
centrally while keeping
employees productive.
Big drum roll.
That's Chrome
Browser Enterprise.
It provides secure, trusted
access to data, apps, and cloud
services.
The browser also connects
employees on any device
and proactively protects
users while they work.
Your users get a consistent,
customizable experience
wherever they want to
work, and IT admins
can easily manage
permissions and policies
across every user, every
device, and every platform
that they have in
their enterprise.
It should be no surprise to
learn that Chrome browser has
been evolving over
the past 10 years
to support enterprise users.
We started with
administrative GPOs
and then we added features,
additional features,
that customers requested
for enterprise use cases.
As the web has grown, so have
our enterprise capabilities.
Also in the past year,
we've added the ability
to manage Chrome browser
from Google's Admin Console.
And we'll detail additional
feature enhancements
later in the presentation.
First, let's talk
about the impact
that Chrome can have on
an average enterprise
of about 20,000 employees.
Forrester Consulting
has said, one, Chrome
is easier to troubleshoot, and
two, help desk turnaround times
are much, much faster.
So overall, end user
productivity increases
and enterprises see tangible
benefits within six months.
This further validates that
Chrome browser can enable
your IT admins, IT help
desk, and employees
to be more productive.
So quick poll of the audience.
How many of you are Chrome
Browser Enterprise users?
Hands higher.
Come on.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
All right, let's talk about
what we've done since last year.
First, we've improved security
in many, many different ways.
The web is a dangerous
place, and we
have blocked third
party processes
from hijacking Chrome.
Two, we've improved the
verification process
for extensions, and we've
prevented deceptive extensions
from being installed
in the enterprise.
Three, we've let enterprise
users know if their enterprise
password has been
compromised and if it's being
used outside of their company.
And last, we've rolled out site
isolation to contain threats.
This is a key differentiator
of Chrome browser
to keep your end users safe.
But, but, but, but no
security discussion
would be complete
without discussing Flash.
For the past 20 years--
yeah, you can laugh.
For the past 20 years,
Flash has helped
shape the way that you
play games, browse the web,
watch videos, and
run applications.
But over the last
few years, Flash
has actually become less common.
Three years ago,
80% of Flash users--
excuse me, 80% of Chrome
users visited a Flash website
once a day.
Now Flash usage is only 6%,
and it continues to decline.
This trend shows
that websites are
moving to open web technologies
such as HTML5 and PWAs,
which are faster and more
efficient than Flash.
So IT admins, hopefully
I'm looking at all of you,
please work with
your software vendors
to find a migration
path away from Flash.
Since Next 2013,
we've also streamlined
how are browsers managed
in existing environments.
For example, we
know a lot of you
use third party tools
such as SCCM and Intune
to manage your applications.
We verified that Chrome browser
GPOs can be configured properly
from these tools and
improved our documentation
to help admins configure
Chrome within these tools.
We've tested that browser
sign in and restrict
sign in pattern
policies work together
to ensure that your users
can sign into Chrome browser
with the correct work email.
Third, many customers
want statistics on how
their users use Chrome browser.
We've built a purely
optional extension
that an administrator can
install on a Chrome browser.
They can monitor the resource
consumption of Chrome browser
by memory, they can see
they're signed in status,
they can see the
connectivity of the device,
and many, many other
machine information--
excuse me, machine
configuration policies.
The extension data is stored
locally in JSON on that device.
So you can use Splunk or
SCCM to read that information
and build your own reports.
Fourth, we've added
relaunch notifications.
These policies allow
you to influence
how often your
user gets reminded
that a new version of Chrome
is available to download.
And many of our
customers had said
that this helps quite a bit with
keeping their users on the most
current version of Chrome.
This is another feature that
we've added recently called
managed by, and it was
built with a lot of feedback
from your employees.
It helps increase
the transparency
between admins and end users.
We're letting employees easily
see the administrative policies
that are being set up
in their environment
so that they know their
browser is being managed.
We definitely expect some
discussion around this feature,
so we will continue to iterate
on it over the next few months
with your feedback.
Now let's move on to
what's happening in 2019.
This is our forward
looking roadmap.
We have a lot of
great features coming.
And I'm going to discuss each
one of these in more detail.
So first, Chrome Browser cloud
management has just launched.
This will enable
admins to easily manage
Chrome deployments of
any size from the cloud.
Admins can enroll devices
into organizational units
and manage all the
desktop Chrome browsers
of these enrolled devices
through Google Admin Console.
They can also apply policies
to organizational units
and deploy those policies to all
the browsers that are enrolled.
Admins will be able to gain
insights into their deployment,
and they will be
able to delegate
admin responsibilities.
So if you have a
large organization,
you could delegate an admin
for finance, an admin for HR,
an admin for sales, an
admin for any other group
that you might have
in your organization.
Note that administrators need
to have a Google account,
but your end users do not.
What we do is that
we enroll the browser
via a token, which admins can
retrieve from the Google Admin
Console.
There's a lot of great
features in this product,
and I won't be able to cover
them all in this session.
Please check out the session
later today with my colleague
Phil and Starbucks
to learn how they
have deployed
Chrome Browser cloud
management at their company.
Next feature, legacy
browser support.
This is a feature
that we've actually
had for a couple years that
allows admins to have Chrome
as the default browser for the
majority of their websites,
but it will allow them to
automatically fall back
to a legacy browser
for some minority
set of legacy websites.
In addition, users are endlessly
switched back to Chrome
from that legacy
browser when they
try to access a modern website.
So it's really, really useful.
While this feature has been
available for many years,
it's now going to be
much easier to deploy,
because it's being
built into Chrome
and you won't have to rely
on an additional extension.
We've actually heard a
lot of great feedback
from this feature from early
adopters of the integrated LBS,
and we really hope
to hear from you
and hope that you
enjoy it as well.
We will also be adding
controls for legacy browser
support into the Admin
Console later this year.
Another feature that
is getting rolled out
is part of a suite of features
called Update Controls.
Many of our customers
have requested the ability
to pin Chrome to
specific versions.
We launched this
feature, and it's
really meant for
companies-- excuse me,
we've already
launched this feature,
and we've gotten
feedback from companies,
and they've told us this is
super helpful when they have
strict management, change
management requirements
and or compliance needs.
What we are now doing is
offering a way for customers
to roll back a new
version of Chrome
to an old version of Chrome.
And this is meant as a
temporary measure or emergency
workaround.
We always recommend to stay on
the newest version of Chrome
so that you're up to date with
the latest security patches.
Today these features are
available as GPO only,
and we will add these
controls to the Admin Console
later this year.
Next, how many of
you use passwords?
I use passwords.
I have a corporate password.
Sometimes I accidentally
use that password outside
of my company.
So we've built a feature
called Password Alert.
This will alert
your employees when
they use their
corporate password
on a non-whitelisted website.
And what the feature
does, it will actually
instruct them to
reset their password.
This prevents
corporate passwords
from being phished by
malicious, third party websites.
We also plan to enable Password
Alert from the Admin Console
so that IT admins
can get reports
on who is reusing their password
outside of their company.
This helps quite a
bit for compliance.
Next.
Chrome browser has
a ton of policies.
We know that we've had
to make improvements
towards documenting
these policies,
and we're going to
update our policy page.
Right now when you go
to our policy list,
it's a huge, just
gigantic web page of 300
plus policies that span
Chrome Browser and Chrome OS.
You've asked for an
easier way to search
through these policies, and
that's what we're doing.
You're going to be able to
filter by operating system,
you're going to be able to
filter by browser version,
and you're going to be able to
filter by a couple other things
to more easily allow you to see
when a new policy was added.
Onto Omnibox.
Omnibox is one of my
most favorite features,
and we continue to look at
Omnibox as a key entry point
for surfacing search results.
Now G Suite admins
have the option
to allow Chrome Omnibox
to show document
suggestions from Google Drive
when a user does a search.
And this is all enabled from
within your company firewall,
not external.
Note that there are three
things that an admin must
do to enable this feature.
One, you have to have
a G Suite account,
and you have to turn
on this setting.
Two, users have to be
signed into Chrome.
That should be obvious.
And three, users have to
have Cloud Sync turned on.
We use this feature
every day Google,
and I can tell you it's
super useful for finding
that document that you
just can't remember.
Another UX related
feature is tab groups,
which is super amazing.
Tab groups will increase
the productivity
for users that want
better tools to manage
their workflows, especially
their business workflows.
You'll be able to
group related tabs
together so that it's easier
to find your work stream
and stay focused.
And those are some
of our major features
that are coming in 2019.
Just as a reminder, we
have an extensive list
of resources for our customers
that don't buy support.
We have release notes,
help center articles,
and a free enterprise forum.
And if you're interested
in purchasing support,
please contact our Chrome
enterprise browser specialists
at google.com and
they'll tell you
what's included in
the support package.
Noriko is right back there.
She's smiling.
Go say hi to her
after the session.
All right.
We're almost done, but we
have many other sessions
today, tomorrow, and
Thursday, and these will all
go into more depth about
Chrome Browser Enterprise.
So if you're trying to pitch
Chrome inside of your company,
I highly recommend checking
out the session with Blue Cross
Blue Shield and their journey to
make Chrome the primary browser
in their enterprise.
[MUSIC PLAYING]